[Musica]
almeno un'ora al giorno bisogna essere
felici
ho letto per la prima volta questa frase
in un negozietto nelle vie di torino e
da quel momento è come se
tante cose che erano successe nella mia
vita fino ad ora acquisissero un senso
questa frase mi sensi molte nella testa
come un tarlo a tal punto che in un
certo senso ne ho fatto il mio lavoro
e
ecco perché oggi voglio raccontarvi tre
delle cose che ho imparato sulla mia
pelle
per lavorare almeno un pochino più
felici
ma facciamo un passo indietro
ricordo esattamente quel giorno della
quinta superiore quando il mio
professore uno dei miei professori
decise di interrogare ad uno ad uno noi
studenti per chiederci che cosa avremmo
voluto fare dopo l'esame
arriva il mio turno
ero negli ultimi banchi quindi non
proprio nato player e mi dice
daverio tu che intenzioni hai
io ero già bella carica bella in grinta
e ho risposto prof io voglio iscrivermi
alla facoltà di psicologia
un attimo di silenzio
daverio ma non far buttar via i soldi
tuoi genitori
bene in silenzio
mi siedo
e proprio lui che avrebbe dovuto
aiutarmi a trovare a coltivare i miei
talenti e a sfruttarli a farli crescere
ne aveva detto che non ce l'avrei fatta
ma io non mi sono data per vinta io mi
sono iscritta a quella facoltà di
psicologia
durante il percorso mi sono follemente
innamorata nell'ambito della psicologia
del lavoro tanto da iscrivermi alla
specialistica in psicologia del lavoro e
del benessere nelle organizzazioni
ecco che tornava questa felicità
ho iniziato il mio percorso e ricerca e
selezione ho continuato occupandomi di
formazione di sviluppo ricoprendo ruoli
specialisti e generalisti fino ad
arrivare a quello di cui mi occupo oggi
people in calce persone e cultura
organizzativa
questa è la prima cosa che ho imparato
trova il lavoro che ami e non lavorerai
un giorno della tua vita ha detto
confucio pareva facile a lui
ecco in un paese come l'italia ancora
vittima del paradigma fantozziano
non è così facile ma io penso di essere
stata fortunata ci ho creduto e il mio
percorso era iniziato brillantemente
nei primi anni vedevo la mia carriera
sfrecciare come un auto in autostrada
andava tutto bene
tutto bene ma non benissimo
piano piano ho iniziato a crescere
dentro di me un malessere che con il
tempo si è trasformato in un dolore
fisico quando entravo nel parcheggio del
mio ufficio una morsa mi chiudeva lo
stomaco e un pugnale mi si puntava lì
tutto il santo giorno fino alla sera
quando salivo in macchina e ha senso di
liberazione
quelli erano gli anni in cui si
incominciava a parlare di cultura
organizzativa anche dentro alle aziende
non solo in università gli anni in cui
il libro powerful di patti mekong
ricciardi netflix stava letteralmente
spopolando
non sono così vecchio è parliamo fugge
34 anni fa è iniziata una lampadina
ho messo a fattor comune le mie
esperienze e mi sono resa conto che
avevo sempre lavorato in aziende molto
simili tra loro con culture rigide
organigrammi quasi iscritti nella pietra
e soprattutto dove a fronte di poche
teste pensanti c'erano tantissimi
esecutori
io non volevo più essere un esecutore io
volevo metterci la faccia volevo firmare
i miei progetti volevo avere un impatto
e allora cosa fare mollare tutto
cambiare vita aprire la propria azienda
ma io amavo il mio lavoro
ecco la seconda cosa che ho imparato
la cultura aziendale è tutto questa è
l'eredità che ci ha lasciato toni se
fondatore di zappos nonché autore del
libro delivering happiness un altro che
consiglio a tutti ea tutte le persone
che vogliono approfondire questi
argomenti
ma che cos'è questa benedetta cultura
organizzativa
ecco probabilmente non basterebbero
decine di tebe per raccontarla quindi
voglio partire dando vi la definizione è
più semplice quella che trovate su
google la cultura organizzativa è
l'insieme di assunti di base che un
gruppo di persone che lavorano nella
stessa azienda
scopre inventa e sviluppa per
coordinarsi internamente e relazionarsi
verso l'esterno in tre parole
quello in cui credono quello che
condividono e come si comportano
ecco che per farmi qualche esempio
davvero concreto vi posso dire che la
cultura organizzativa è darsi del tu può
darsi del lei la cultura organizzativa è
avere un dress code ben definito e
quindi sapere la domenica che tutta la
settimana e già il tuo guardaroba oppure
essere liberi di indossare quello che si
vuole e cultura timbrare il cartellino
ci sono aziende che fondano il proprio
operato su quel bip all'ingresso e
all'uscita
oppure ci sono aziende che lasciano
completa libertà e quello che guida e la
consegna del progetto rispettare la data
ecco la cultura organizzativa è così
profonda che
può arrivare a raccontare la storia
dell'azienda anche all'esterno a
diventare il vero e proprio segno
distintivo il suo brand ecco che è
subito quella voglia di indossare un
paio di scarpette andarsi a fare una
corsa quando pensate a nike quella
voglia di stringere l'ultimo iphone
quando passate davanti al negozio della
apple o ancora quella voglia di aria in
faccia e nei capelli per chi ce li ha
quando sentite il rumore di un harley
davidson
e quindi di rete che tu cosa hai fatto
io ho iniziato a cercare
ho iniziato a cercare qualcosa di
diverso ho incontrato questa realtà che
molto diversa da tutte le altre direi un
po più pane salame rispetto alle aziende
per cui avevo lavorato fino a quel
momento stava cercando qualcuno che li
aiutasse a tradurre la loro cultura già
molto forte ma non ancora condivisa
formalmente e trasformarla in un ampio
experience quindi nell'esperienza di
ciascun dipendente in maniera
completamente coerente per mettere al
centro di questa stessa strategia
proprio le persone che facevo mi perdevo
questa opportunità quindi l'ho colta al
volo e dopo uno shock iniziale
letteralmente ho capito che questo
contesto fondato su tre pilastri
ambizione velocità e concretezza
era un contesto in cui potevo essere me
stessa
potevo dare il meglio di me
potevo proporre progetti dire le mie
idee potevo sbagliare e imparare da
quegli errori
ecco che ho capito che per me piana
questo tipo di cultura e la cultura in
cui mi trovo meglio in cui posso dare il
massimo in cui l'unico limite
sono io il budget perché
a me piace paragonare la cultura ad un
abito su misura
come un abito la cultura infatti può
essere
inserita in particolari momenti e quindi
non ditemi che metterebbe un abito per
un matrimonio ad una cena informale con
amici allo stesso modo la cultura può
cambiare così come possiamo cambiare noi
basta sbagliare un lavaggio e il vestito
ce lo siamo dimenticati e allo stesso
modo può cambiare la nostra fisicità e
quindi quel vestito ahimè non c entra
più e quindi è così mutevole da rendere
fondamentale la terza cosa che ho
imparato
siamo la somma delle scelte che
prendiamo questo invece l'ha detto jeff
bezos tra i suoi gli oggetti nello
spazio e questa cosa l'ho imparata
all'inizio del mio percorso quando mi
occupavo di ricerca e selezione
infatti spesso siamo portati a pensare
che le scelte che riguardano la sfera
professionale
abbiano una causalità esogena quindi
provengano da qualcosa di esterno
rispetto a noi
la realtà non è così la realtà è che
quando un'azienda sceglie proprio noi
tra centinaia migliaia di curriculum
il peso della nostra risposta
nell'accettare o meno quella offerta è
esattamente lo stesso
perché se abbiamo capito che cosa ci
piace fare e soprattutto come vogliamo
farlo in che tipo di cultura vogliamo
realizzarci ecco che abbiamo pieno
diritto di dire sì o no a una promozione
un cambio di ruolo a un nuovo lavoro
e quindi sono queste per me tre cose
veramente importanti per lavorare un
pochino più felice e aumentare la nostra
soddisfazione
passione cultura e consapevolezza di
poter scegliere
perché fare il lavoro che amo
e farlo all'interno di un'azienda
in cui credo fermamente di cui condivido
pienamente la cultura e sapere che oggi
è così ma domani può cambiare sono tre
delle ragioni che ogni mattina mi fanno
spegnere la sveglia uscire dal letto
prepararmi andare in ufficio e prender
quelle ore di felicità
e voi vi siete mai chiesti quali sono le
vostre ragioni per spegnere quella
maledetta sveglia
[Applauso]